[Musique]
il ya dix ans j'étais étudiant ici alice
a lyon on théâtre est une
et d'ailleurs il ya dix ans presque jour
pour jour j'étais presque au jour de ma
première représentation de terre ici là
sur scène et ce soir-là il m'est arrivé
une histoire incroyable un truc de fou
j'ai eu sur c'est une aventure avec au
moins 8 copine que je venais de
rencontrer ce soir par ici et le plus
incroyable dans tout ça parce que une
histoire avec une copine passe encore
pourquoi pas mais le plus incroyable
c'est que cette histoire a duré jusqu'à
présent que nous sommes inséparables et
que pour rien au monde je ne choisirai
une plus que les autres c'est lui
copines sont venues avec moi seul soit
je voulais présenter mais pour être tout
à fait exact avant d'aller plus loin il
me semble que je vous dois la vérité sur
un détail
ces huit copine rencontrés un soir de
théâtre ne sont pas des femmes mais des
émotions
vous savez les émotions tout le monde en
ressent 15-16 par jour si par exemple je
m'approche de monsieur assis au premier
rang innocemment et qui sait peut-être
que dans l'été dicks il est parfois
d'usagé de demander au public de monter
sur scène pour interagir avec le speaker
monsieur qui s'appelle baptiste selon
qui il ressent tout d'abord de la
surprise puis une fois la surprise
passée toujours selon qui il est
baptiste ressent soit de la peur auquel
cas il est déjà en train de faire non de
la tête avant que rapproche
soit l inverse de l'intérêt de
l'excitation
auquel cas il est déjà debout prêt à
répondre à une question que j'ai pas
encore posé ce que j'ai découvert ce
soir là c'est exactement ça baptiste agi
en fonction de ses émotions
les émotions qu'ils le ressentent qu'il
ressent le pousse à agir et à s'adapter
à cette situation il décide pas par un
processus strictement rationnelle de se
mettre à faire longue date est en se
disant c'est bon si je fais et non de la
tête assez longtemps il va finir par
aller voir quelqu'un d'autre c'est son
émotion qu'il pousse et ça c'est le sens
étymologique du mot émotions du verbe
émouvoir et modérée en latin mettre en
mouvement
faire faire quelque chose et c'est
exactement ce que j'ai compris ce
soir-là au théâtre simon texte me
demande de faire quelque chose si mon
texte me demande d'offrir des fleurs à
une fille parce que je suis amoureux il
faut que je ressente l'émotion qui va
derrière parce que offrir des fleurs à
une fille parce qu'on est amoureux et
offrir des fleurs à une fille juste
parce qu'on fait semblant d'être
amoureux et que c'est écrit dans le
texte
ces deux choses entièrement différente
ça rien à voir je vous renvoie vos
expériences personnelles
plus largement au théâtre stanislavski
un bon metteur en scène un grand metteur
en scène qui mettait en scène tchekhov
est resté célèbre pour une phrase qu'il
lançait à ces acteurs quand ils
croyaient pas à leurs émotions quand il
avait l'impression qu'il jouait pas
sincèrement leur faisait gagner vers lui
le monsieur était russe en français je
n'y crois pas alors disait ce que vous
jouez là le texte que vous interprétez
vous y mettez pas c'est d'émotion que
vous n'y êtes pas entièrement
et quelque part cette phrase m'a pas mal
marqué elle m'a marqué pour les
spectacles suivants de théâtre que j'ai
pu jouer dans cette scène et surtout
elle a donné dans ma vie toute la place
qu'elle mérite et amélie copine puis le
spectacle de théâtre en spectacle de
théâtre
tout arrive j'ai fini mes études j'ai
une
diplômé j'ai commencé à travailler et là
par contre en commençant à travailler
j'ai cru recevoir le message que les
émotions n'ont pas leur place au travail
tanguy bail mais oui copine n'était par
exemple dans mes deux premières années
en mission sur un chantier
j'avais construit un beau tableau de
bord un fichier excel qui disait à
chacun sur le chantier ce qu'ils
devaient faire
comment il devait le faire à quel moment
un vrai sujet pour un ingénieur insa
nouvellement diplômés puis sur chantier
il y avait un collègue qui avait une
expérience de furieux qui avait bossé
partout dans le monde qui avait tout
fait qu'ils avaient tous vécu et qui
quelque part fait un petit peu peur
aussi à tout le monde parce que
verbalement il pouvait être violent et
un jour ce collègue en question il
arrive dans mon bureau en gueulant fait
qu'est ce que c'est que cette bouse de
table bord qu'on m'impose encore comme
met dans les pattes on va pas me laisser
bosser un peu
alors moi en face j'étais morte de
trouille est littéralement donc des prix
la réaction la plus proche que j'avais à
disposition je bomber le torse et dit
c'est comme ça et pas autrement
chef de chantier qui est entendu que ça
gueulait il est venu dans le bureau il a
demandé ce qui se passait il a demandé à
ce qu'on lui explique et je pense que le
collègue en question faisait aussi peur
à ce chef de chantier pour seul chef de
chantier tout ce qu'il a trouvé à faire
c'est bomber le torse dire c'est comme
ça et pas autrement
et ce collègue là je suis pas sûr mais
je pense qu'il est énervé je pense qu'il
était en colère
ce qui me fait dire ça c'est qu'il
restait un mois sans me parler après
et pendant ce mois là on va peu à peu
tranquillement j'ai compris que mon
tableau de bord il servait pas à grand
chose et que c'était peut-être pour ça
qu'il était en colère la base vous
imaginez coutu truc si on avait parlé de
nos peurs si j'avais parlé de ma peur si
le chef de chantier avait parlé des
siennes si lui avait simplement dit
pourquoi ils étaient en colère on aurait
gagné à un brin phénoménal phénoménal
mais les émotions n'ont pas leur place
au travail ou tout au moins je le
croyais et ça aurait pu continuer de
longues années comme ça j'aurais pu
garder mes copines au placard assez
longtemps mais deux ans après j'ai
appris que j'avais une sclérose en
plaques
on est peu de chose sclérose en plaques
une inflammation du système sap du
système nerveux qui mettra peut-être
dans un fauteuil roulant en 10 ou 15 ans
mon système immunitaire qui s'attaque au
système nerveux
alors ça côté émotionnel c'est un peu la
catastrophe
je suis effondré je me suis dit que rien
ne valait la peine d'être vécue je
voulais mourir et j'en avais assez lui
et puis tout parce qu'arnaud pour preuve
je suis ici aujourd'hui est plutôt
heureux d'être là et du coup quand j'ai
appris ça et le temps de digérer un peu
annonce j'ai décidé de changer de
travail
j'ai décidé de mettre au centre de ma
vie l'humain le management et puis
surtout mes huit copine alors je me suis
formé au coaching à l'accompagnement de
dirigeants je me suis associé dans une
société de coaching de conseil en
management sur lyon avec fierté tu aimes
allée jusqu'à écrire un livre et dans ce
livre il ya un chapitre entier qui est
consacré aux émotions qui parle de mes
lui copine et si ce livre devait deux
fois plus court je pense que je garderai
en entier le chapitre sur mary copines
sur les émotions j'en changerai rien
n'en retirerai pas une lettre alors
qu'est ce qui a changé
j'ai eu l'impression dans ma formation
au boulot dans mon nouveau boulot et en
écrivant qu'on me parlait tout le temps
des motions pourquoi qu'est ce qui a
changé pour moi ya deux choses
il ya eu deux évolutions majeures la
première c'est déjà que notamment pour
écrire mon livre je suis tombé sur
beaucoup de recherche qui parle des
émotions dans un cap professionnel je
vous en présente quelques unes
google a sponsorisé une étude pour
trouver le principal critère
d'efficacité d'une équipe dans le monde
professionnel
est ce que ça marche dans les gens sont
plus intelligentes
est ce que ça marche quand les gens
viennent d'horizons variés qu'est ce qui
fait qu'une équipe est efficace
qu'est-ce qui fait l'efficacité d'une
équipe la seule chose qu'il trouve
statistiquement méthode google
statistiques à l'appui c'est que ce qui
fait l'efficacité d'une équipe c'est ce
qu'ils appellent la sécurité
psychologique est ce que les différents
membres d'une équipe se sentent
suffisamment en confiance avec les
autres membres
pour parler de ce qu'ils sont
profondément pour parler de leurs
émotions pour admettre qu'ils ont fait
des erreurs pour partager leurs moments
de gêne ou leurs problèmes personnels
première étude sur quatre la deuxième un
peu plus ancien c'est darwin darwin qui
dit un truc qui est limpide qui est
d'une simplicité biblique il dit non à
théorie de l'évolution
tout le monde a évolué et on a gardé ce
qui marchait
donc si on a des émotions aujourd'hui
c'est que les émotions ont marché par
exemple si je suis un homme des cavernes
quelqu'un vole mon bifteck je ressens de
la colère
la colère est fonctionnel parce qu'elle
n'amène à me battre pour récupérer mon
bifteck et ça il ya pas de raison que ça
soit arrêté à la fin de l'âge des
cavernes
c'était vrai à une époque c'est toujours
vrai maintenant les émotions étaient
fonctionnelles elles le sont toujours
deuxième et une troisième des chercheurs
en intelligence artificielle qui disent
si un jour on veut avoir une véritable
intelligence artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle autonome
intelligente au sens humain du terme
la prochaine étape c'est pas plus de
puissance de calcul c'est de créer un
système émotionnelle qui permettent sa
régulation
quatrième et une dame as you qui
démontre un neurologue qui démontre que
dans le cerveau on a un système qui
prend les décisions et on a un système
qui permet de d'amener les émotions dans
le cerveau entre guillemets si on
déconnecte ces deux systèmes
on est un fou de prendre une décision
rationnelle qui va dans notre intérêt on
pense pendant tous les jours des
décisions rationnelles on dit ici alors
b si j'ai fait ça c'est parce que ceux
ci c'est parce que cela est derrière
tout ça à chaque fois il ya nos émotions
et si on retire nos émotions on est
infoutue de prendre la décision
rationnelle qui va donc tout ça c'est
toutes ces études et d'autres encore
c'est la première chose qui a changé et
la deuxième chose et qui est peut-être
la plus importante fait que j'ai arrêté
mais arrêtez d'écouter ceux qui disent
que les émotions n'ont pas leur place au
travail dirigeants managers clients y
compris et ça ça change tout
et ça c'est phénoménal parce que du coup
j'ai commencé à développer une curiosité
pour les émotions des gens que je
rencontrais mes collègues mes clients
j'ai commencé à chercher quelle émotion
et ressentez alors demandé comment vous
vous sentez qu'elle est l'émotion qui
vous fait dire ceci quelles émotions qui
vous fait dire cela
ça vous pourrez essayer c'est le genre
de question quand on les pose la
première fois on sent un n'a pas
l'habitude allez demander aux gens
comment ils s'y sentent sais pas ce
qu'on fait tous les jours mais parfois
néanmoins les gens m'ont répondu avec
des émotions avec un peu d'insistance
parfois et à chaque fois leurs
problématiques se sont éclairées comme
si c'était la pièce du puzzle manquant
des dirigeants qui avaient peur de la
cote de leurs collaborateurs
les managers qui était en collecte en
coupables en colère contre d'autres
personnes qui savaient pas que faire
qu'ils savaient pas que dire d'autres
dirigeants qui avaient honte des
décisions qui devaient prendre à chaque
fois l'émotion venait clairet leurs
problématiques comme une pièce manquante
du puzzle comme quelque chose qui était
à disposition et qui ne demandait qu'à
être digne alors néanmoins
l'inconvénient quand on demande à
quelqu'un comment il s'en c'est que par
défaut ils répondent tout sauf une
émotion comment ça va comment tu te sens
très bien merci
notamment pas de problème j'ai bien
dormi cette nuit c'est sympa j'ai passé
une bonne soirée merci de demander tout
sauf des émotions je suis allé un petit
peu plus loin les prix du papier des
ciseaux de la colle et j'ai fait un cube
et à chaque sommet j'ai mis un nombre
d'émotions et du coup quand quelqu'un me
répond avec autre chose que l'on
d'émotion lui donne le cube vive fait
une hypothèse
imaginez vous ressentiez une émotion là
tout de suite à l'instant t
quelle émotion sa sereine où est ce que
vous seriez sur le cube et à chaque fois
il ya des choses magnifiques qui sont
déjà en retourne le cube dans tous les
sens se demande
vraiment je vois pas trop d'émotions si
je vous demandais à tout de suite qui
ressent une émotion
vous seriez sans doute très peu a levé
la main mais si je vous donnais que vous
commenciez à chercher de routards
entreprises et à chaque fois encore une
fois c'est la pièce manquante du puzzle
comment ça marche je sais pas peut-être
que comme au théâtre
quand on parle de nos émotions à nos
interlocuteurs qu'ils nous sont plus
alignés ils ont l'impression de nous
voir en cohérence avec ce qu'on ressent
et avec ce qu'on fait peut-être que ça
les fait peut-être aussi plus
basiquement que quand on parle de nos
émotions
ça nous aide nous mêmes à mieux nous
comprendre quand je préparais cette aide
je le sentais honnêtement pas du tout
puis j'ai pris mon cul j'ai cherché je
suis qu'un homme pas du tout séparément
d'émotion ça je me suis dit que c'était
quelque part entre la peur et la honte
entre la peur et la honte de ne pas être
à la hauteur de me retrouver face à vous
et ne pas avoir de message pertinent à
donner ou ne pas savoir comment lire
mais une fois qu'on a mis le doigt
dessus on a prises là dessus j'ai fermé
les yeux
j'ai imaginé ce moment précis sur la fin
de monteils en imaginant que tous vous y
aviez trouvé quelque chose qui vous
convenait et je me suis demandé ce que
j'avais fait pour en arriver là
j'ai réécrit 3 x man tête mais surtout
plus important que sentiment de honte ou
de peur avait disparu
tout ce que je peux vous souhaitez c'est
d'aller à la rencontre de vos émotions
votre travail ou dans le champ perso ça
sur la peur de la gêne ce soit des
émotions positives comme négatives
importe d'aller faire connaissance avec
elle et puis surtout quand vous croisez
mais lui copine transmettaient leur mais
cette mutation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]